this is one of those problems that seems
like it would be really complicated to
fix but turns out to have a simple
solution but then that solution turns
out to be really complicated this is
greens in switzerland it's a small
alpine village surrounded by absolutely
beautiful hills and mountains that
occasionally try to kill people this
whole hillside is slowly sliding and
slipping down it can't hold itself up
most of the time it's silent and still
but occasionally a load of heavy rocks
will tumble down
actually i feel like heavy rocks isn't
really getting the point across this is
one of the rocks and worst case it'll
travel across that road at ten or twenty
kilometers an hour sideways the scans
the door um
the village is safe from the big
individual rockfalls it's far enough
away the road here
not so much it'll be far too expensive
to build massive protection barriers all
along there and besides the odds of a
boulder actually hitting a car are small
but not zero so what you want is
something that can automatically detect
rock falls and close the road
simple solution
a radar
and a stop light so if the radar detects
rockfall in a certain defined area it
triggers an alarm the traffic lights go
red and then the radar tracks the
rockfall if the rockfall stops or it
ends up in the dam
then the traffic light switches off goes
back to normal
the road is safe to pass if the rockfall
ends up somewhere close to the road the
traffic light switches to flashing
orange which means drive carefully
because a bully could be on the road or
the road could be damaged
radar has the large benefit that it
works in all weather in all visibility
conditions radar waves can penetrate
fog rainfall snowfall and hence works
day and night and in all visibility
conditions which is needed for an alarm
system the traffic lights are about 450
meters apart
which is the area considered as
dangerous for the for the traffic we've
got about 40 seconds from
detachment to
a rock reaching the road and this is
just enough for the cars to escape the
dangerous area they have to drive a
certain velocity otherwise they can't
get away and this is why cyclists are
not allowed on this road here's the
complicated bit you can't just have this
stop traffic anytime the radar detects
movement birds would set it off my drone
would set it off mischievous kids
throwing pebbles would set it off on
that note
how do you calibrate something like this
we don't have a lot of false alarms it's
very rare that we close the road because
of something else for example
an approaching rain front that could
look kind of similar since this is such
an active site this is the perfect site
to tune your algorithms or to develop
the algorithms at all we installed the
radar 2017
and after a test period of about a year
it went live with the traffic lights
and since installation we've detected
five and a half thousand events from an
engineering perspective setting up a
radar and a stop light is the easy part
the complicated part is working out the
balance between false positives where
the road's going to be closed half the
time and false negatives where cars
could get hit by boulders now i haven't
seen any rock falls here today and i
also haven't seen the lights change and
their logs now have thousands of rock
falls where the lights did turn red
so i'd say they've probably got it about
right
i mean i know it was too much to hope
for i was just hoping there'd be just a
little rock fall as i finished just just
like just a little one not doing any
damage just just a few
let's let's do that again
let's do that again without worrying
that rock's gonna hit me